[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Edward ruggah Murr an associate
professor of african-american studies
and history at Yale he studies
comparative slavery and abolition and
Antebellum u.s. history today we'll talk
with professor Raghu Murr about his new
book slave law and the politics of
resistance in the early Atlantic world
for which he was recently awarded the
macmillan centers gustav Ranas
international book prize for best book
welcome professor rather than learn
thank you so let's start with your book
tell us about it it's a comparative
study of Jamaica and South Carolina for
a fairly long period of time starting in
the 17th century when both of these
colonies are established and extending
into the 1830s and I take that I take
that with what's called the longer a
approach because I wanted to understand
how the politics of slavery evolved over
time and how that shaped the political
history of both these slave societies
these slave colonies in indistinct ways
okay and so it really the first chapters
actually on Barbados because Barbados is
England's first slave Society and both
Jamaica and South Carolina are
established by men who had been very
involved in the establishment Barbados
and had seen the the lucrative how
profitable slavery was in Barbados okay
and they wanted to establish the same
thing in Jamaica and South Carolina but
because of the different geographies and
because North America and the Caribbean
are very different places and the
different possibilities for crops that
were that were in both of these places
they evolved in distinct ways and and
and so most of the book is really
focused on that and that power dialectic
between slave resistance which is a
constant but sometimes emerges in
rebellions I'm particularly interested
in slave rebellions and then on the
other side the the way that masters
responded to these things the way
slaveholders respond to these things
principally through the law and I was
interested in in how the Hallie's
English and British assemblies codified
slavery and and the laws allow us to see
not necessarily the social reality of
the of these slave societies but the way
that masters wanted these slave
societies to be governed the way they
wanted things to to run and I I take
that I take that dynamic and I follow it
straight up to the 1830s when slavery
was abolished in Jamaica in part because
of a major slave rebellion that happens
in 1831 known as the Baptist war in
Jamaica and in response to that and in
response to sustained abolitionist
pressure the British abolished slavery
in 1834 and that's precisely the moment
in US history when South Carolina
emerges as really the most aggressive
pro-slavery state and the planters there
are defending slavery as what John
Calhoun called a positive good for for
human relations leading towards the
session in the civil war which which I
don't cover in the book but that's but
that's certainly foreshadowed ok and
what led you to study this well I I had
long wanted to do a comparative study
because of well when I was in graduate
school - two important books came out in
the scholarship on slavery IRA Berlin's
many thousands gone and Philip Morgan's
slave counterpoint
and they're both comparative studies of
slavery but neither one really grasped
the politics of slavery and the way I
thought was really important and I still
believe this is very important to
understanding slave societies okay let's
let's stop there and talk about that for
a minute about the politics of right yes
and why you feel it so important well I
don't think we can understand the slave
societies without seeing the struggle at
the heart of it and neither of the lot
of literature hasn't really dealt with
the significance of slave resistance I
mean it a lot of people a lot of
historians acknowledge slave resistance
is there and we have great studies of
slave resistance but what did it mean
how is it significant and for example
what I do in the book is I show how this
dynamic between enslaved people and the
masters shaped Jamaica and South
Carolina and distinctive ways what I
call the domestication of slavery in
South Carolina and the militarization of
slavery in Jamaica and and what that
meant was that when you when when when
the American Revolution when its
beginning this imperial crisis that
leads the American Revolution when that
begins the planters in these two slave
societies are in very different
positions these Avi their slaves to be
able to confront the British on policies
that they saw as oppressive right so I
argue that it's it's it's the way these
are slight societies had evolved which
allowed South Carolina to join the
patriot movement and become part of the
United States and really inhibits
Jamaica hits the Jamaican planters from
doing that they are too dependent upon
the military apparatus of the British
Empire in Jamaica to really establish to
really join with the revolution even
though they shared a lot of the same
ideas as as Patriots and
mainland colonies did okay so you begin
in Barbados and a lot of the same men
who helped create the slavery situation
in Barbados worked in Jamaica as well as
South Carolina but yet you're saying
that Jamaica and South Carolina kind of
evolved in a very different way right
let's talk about how different they were
give us some ideas of what specifically
was different okay so for example
there's their sizeable Indian
populations in South Carolina what
becomes South Carolina as the English
arrived and and really the principal
economy for early South Carolina is
trade with with indigenous policies in
the area and enslaving was really
important for that the capture of
indigenous people and signed them as
slaves to the northern colonies and also
to the Caribbean and in South Carolina's
are also enslaving people on their own
plantations but that era of slaving ends
in in the yemassee war of 1715 with is
this violent outburst is a very bloody
war and in the aftermath of that war
which almost destroys the colony though
if you follow the law which is one of
the things I did the law actually
becomes less harsh not saying that
slavery becomes less harsh but the
assembly clearly wants to curb the most
sadistic slaveholders and that is
fascinating because these are the men
who are in South Carolina who are really
supporting slavery so that is kind of a
dichotomy between the plantation owners
and those people who are making law so
how do you explain the plantation owners
are the ones making well okay so then
then why do you think the laws were
softened because I think they were
concerned about about about resistance I
think they were concerned about the the
the level of warfare they had seen the
yemassee war I think they were very
worried about and there had been a lot
of rebellions in the Caribbean and this
is an interconnected world and
Caroline's are very aware of the threat
of slavery value okay
and then in South Carolina with the the
the Stono rebellion of 1739 after that
they cut off the slave trade right and
they're trying to they pass a new slave
code in 1740 which continues that trend
of softening that we'd seen in the 1720s
and 1730's but the idea in South
Carolina was to was to make slavery a
permanent institution you within a
society to soften it in order to prolong
it okay right to make it permanent in
Jamaica it's and you make it they don't
do that they pass one slave code in 1696
they don't change it until the end of
the 18th century mm-hmm right and they
depend upon military force there's a
permanent garrison of British troops in
Jamaica during that whole time which
really that garrison begins its its
presence in the island through the first
maroon war which is this the Maroons are
Africans who escaped into the mountains
of Jamaica as early as the as the
English conquest in 1655 and they are
able to defend their autonomy from the
colony there are Africans but they're
free and the colony tries in in the
1730's the colony tries to suppress the
Maroons but they don't they end up in a
draw they made that they assign treaties
and and it's after the it's it's in the
war and after the trees that this
garrison this military garrison in
Jamaica becomes a permanent fixture and
so the Jamaicans are controlling their
society through military force in a way
the Carolinians are not and that means
that with the Imperial crisis and the
American Revolution you have instances
of organized slave resistance in both
places okay and in Jamaica when that
happens when there's this big conspiracy
in Hanover in this in this parish on
that on the north coast and when that
happens
Jamaicans who had been sympathetic to
the the critiques of empire being
offered in the 13 colonies
they just back off and they there is no
more movements toward supporting the
America becomes the American and why is
that
they're terrified they'd they're
dependent upon British military force to
keep the slaves in check okay and that's
not the case in South Carolina I say
right they're able to whites are able to
do it themselves
okay you know and doing how did you do
the research for the book and were there
any surprises along the way that you
just didn't per se
it's it's mostly archival I mean I've I
looked at all the all the published
collections of laws of course but the
kind of the method of the book is to is
to deeply contextualize the passage of
these slave codes as they took place and
in the case of Jamaica documents in this
first maroon war and the rebellions that
follow that and and the establishment
the garrison and the way the governor's
could use the garrison so it's archival
research principally in Jamaica and
South Carolina and in the UK in the
British Library in cue the National
Archives I mean that's where a lot of
the sources are okay and what about what
were the codes like what were some of
them the actual laws the codes are very
very extensive and in a way what's
interesting about the codes and this did
surprise me there are the codes are not
really directed toward enslaved people
they're directed toward whites and the
way white should govern enslave people
so if an enslaved person does this the
owner is required to punish in this sort
of a way and so it's it's it's it's the
Assembly's effort to shape the way the
white society acts in the governance of
its own slaves and so and that changes
over time in response to these moments
of organized resistance where and where
the next generation of slaveholders
realize okay
especially in the case of South Carolina
this earlier way of doing things should
be changed and so they pass a new a new
code in the in the Jamaica context you
don't see that they don't adjust their
slave code until they come under
pressure from the abolitionists from
from abolitionists in Great Britain and
it's when they want to save face it's
when it's when the Jamaicans want to
when the white Jamaicans want to portray
their slavery as more humane than it was
is when they begin to change their laws
to reflect that what is there any
conversations back and forth between
Jamaica and South Carolina in terms of
trying to figure out how best to proceed
early on there is the in fact of South
Carolina's first slave code which is
passed in 1691 is is basically a copy of
Jamaica slave code hmm passed a couple
years before and so they just they just
didn't you know a whole cloth you just
took the slave code after that not so
much okay there is a lot of Commerce
back and forth between Jamaica and South
Carolina there Carolina merchants who
are based in Kingston Kingston there's
this trade back and forth but not really
about about the governance I expected
based on other comparative studies I
read I expected and hoped to find more
of that but I really didn't I looked for
it in the you know I looked for it in my
research but right so no collusion
really whatsoever except in that earlier
period there was quite a bit of bar of
legal parley
but after that the societies really
evolved evolve in their own way so when
slavery was abolished in Jamaica
how did South Carolina react do they
have any reaction in particular yes that
was what was the subject of my first
book because my first book is about the
impact of Great Britain's abolition
slavery on the United States and how
that shaped the coming of the Civil War
this debate you know about what's the
future of slavery going to be in the
United States and the South Carolina
response is in a way is really the
elaboration of the pro-slavery argument
and the development of the idea of the
idea that slavery the maintenance of
slavery was fundamental to the
constitutional compact right that the
states had signed and that the states
had had agreed to and that Congress had
no right to legislate slavery in in in
South Carolina's view and and they stood
by that political stance and that that's
not solely as a result of British
abolition but British abolition is
certainly one of the events that leads
Carolinians to make this argument okay
and who are some of the players both in
Jamaica and in South Carolina some of
the players Weller's there's slave
rebels like like Jackie you know in
Jamaica like Samuel sharp later in
Jamaica like Denmark Vesey in South
Carolina mm-hmm and then there's also
there's also slaveholders people like
Henry Laurens and revolutionary South
Carolina that's really influential
edward long the Jamaicans late historian
slave holder and then he writes a long
three-volume history of Jamaica he's
very involved and you know in trying to
blunt the impact of the abolitionist
movement okay and what about the
political scene during this time who are
some of the political players well I
don't know in high politics you mean
mm-hmm I mean towards the end of the
book John Calhoun began you know player
plays a significant role um Henry
Laurens and high politics earlier on you
know that the Jamaicans are represented
by by agents and so
one of the individuals I really paid a
lot of attention it was my name's Steven
fuller who is the long for a very long
time he's the agent of the Jamaica
assembly in London so he's basically a
lobbyist and he's lobbying Parliament
for Jamaican interests right and how you
know how the how the Empire is run and
he has his own agenda for the way it
should be run and he's a very
influential and influential man he can
get meetings for the prime minister
things like that well and then when the
abolitionists really started to press
hard you know what was his response I
mean I think he probably lost some favor
obviously with some of the politicians
back in London at the time now sure the
West Indians become unpopular but it
takes a while mm-hmm it takes a while
and fuller is actually very involved in
orchestrating the West Indian response
and he has meeting there's a lot of
absent T's so these are these are men
who own plantations in the Caribbean but
they live in London and they live in
other parts of the UK and they they have
the Society of West Indian merchants and
planters and that's a society that dates
back to the early 18th century and they
have regular meetings especially when
when they're faced with the abolitionist
threat mm-hmm - how are we going to
blunt this how are we going to convince
Parliament that the the ideas of these
activists who they see as radicals are
are irrelevant and they should not
influence Imperial policy right right
and so there's this political struggle
within good so then once abolition did
take place in Jamaica how were the rules
changed the laws changed at that point I
mean did they just get stricken from the
book did they get watered down what
exactly happened well there's no more
slave code okay which is significant
there's no more so it just went away it
did but that that's not to say that and
this is beyond that this is beyond the
busker Busker book but what happens is
is that Assemblies come up with
different ways to circumscribe the
movements and opportunities available to
black people and they there's a famous
book on on the early 20th century South
by David Ashim CD called slavery under
another name no that's that the Douglas
Blackmon book slavery under another name
right and that's what happens after
emancipation is that these the planters
legislatures create a different
infrastructure legal and physical to
maintain the compulsion of people of
those who had been enslaved to keep keep
on working for very very little pay and
and that happens in both the American
South after the Civil War but in Jamaica
beginning in the late 18th or right
right so it took a while for things to
really truly change right oh yeah so
what would you like people to take away
from your book what do you conclude well
I conclude that I mean one of it one of
the big takeaways is that what it is
that makes American slavery a more
durable institution okay then it's in
the Caribbean counterpart and least in
the British Empire is is independence is
the achievement of national independence
and that the South Carolinians have a
place at the table and the governance of
the United States they're represented in
the Congress and in the House and the
Senate
they have a say they can they can shape
governance in a way that they're
Jamaican counterparts that they're
Caribbean counterparts cannot and that
and what that means is that when
abolition when abolitionism emerges in
the United States which is really
influenced by the emergence and success
of the British movement right that slave
holders in the United States are in a
far more formidable position to blunt
abolitionism
we're the Jamaican planters in their
West Indian counterparts they were not
in that position they couldn't do
anything about British about public
opinion in Britain Carolinians could and
Carolinians could could they had real
power it was a big difference well this
has been very interesting thank you so
much for being here with us today
thank you yeah pleasure for more
information about Professor rubber and
his research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you